Wow!
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god!
Sorry, I had to push back the stream 50 minutes later because I always need a little cool down in between streams.
I didn't expect the other stream to last for this long!
It went a lot longer than I expected.
I was not expecting it.
To be fair, it was my own fault that the stream did last an hour longer than it should have.
Because, you know, I decided to...
I decided to prolong it a little bit longer because I wanted to pick and choose the placements of Monopoly.
I was very surprised that I did win in the end because I thought like, oh, all I had to do was land on Pippa's square and that was it.
But then, like, I never got to land on Pippa's square.
So, yay!
I don't know how...
Apparently, I'm unlucky in life but very lucky in video games.
Which, I don't know.
I don't know if that's like better or not.
Like, I would like to be lucky in life as well.
Like...
That's true.
I wanted the true Monopoly.
I wanted true Monopoly and took off all the properties.
I saw someone in my comment section was like, how many VTubers does it take to start Monopoly?
One!
Literally me!
I told everybody, like, how to start Monopoly.
Literally, one and it's me.
But no one listened!
They were like, oh, I just thought about listening to Fillion.
I'm listening to Fillion?!
Except instead of me?!
Um...
But yeah, I thought it was a good time.
A good time to...
To relax with some Fallout 4.
Um, I was thinking about it.
I was thinking about doing a...
Should I do a strength build?
Should I go all in on the games chat?
Like, on Melee?
Do I do it?
All in on Melee?
Hehehehe.
Melee and two intelligence.
I feel like I'm gonna fuck myself over with that.
But like...
It's the roleplay.
It's all about the RP.
Also my...
You guys might see the game on...
You guys might see the game, but I don't.
Why is it a black screen?!
I don't... I don't see the game at all!
I just see... I see the game on...
Okay, I'm gonna restart my game.
I see it on my stream, but I...
You guys can see it, but I can't.
I can't see the game.
It's okay.
Todd intended it, guys.
We all know...
Todd decides what I can see and what I can't see.
Do you guys see this?
You guys see this, but I don't.
Oh my god, why?
Okay, let me google this.
Black screen...
Fall out...
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Todd intended this, guys.
Todd...
Todd intended this!
Okay, I have to go to my...
What?!
Okay, and change your settings to the following.
Excuse me?!
Okay, let's see.
Give me a sec, guys.
Why?!
It worked before!
Okay, I can see this.
I'm watching out of my...
I'm watching it out of my OBS at the moment.
Okay, let's see.
Maybe I can find it on my OBS.
Is it because I turned off motion blur?
That was the only thing I fucking changed.
I just changed motion blur.
I just didn't want motion blur.
Does Todd want me to have motion blur?
Of course, Todd.
Of course, you would want me to have motion blur.
Is that why?!
Todd!
Did you want me to play with motion blur on?!
No, it's not because of it.
No, okay.
Okay.
It's not because of motion blur.
Guys, we're gonna figure this out.
Guys, make sure you have the latest...
Okay, I got that.
Try changing... change your AA or shadow distance.
This rewrites...
Okay, we gotta change the AA or shadow distance.
And then we should be good.
Alright.
It's okay.
It's not his fault.
Okay, I'm turning off motion blur.
What's AA?
Anonymous?
What the fuck is AA?
It says change AA or shadow distance.
What the fuck is that?
What's AA?
Okay, I'm gonna put shadow distance at...
Ultra.
I'll see all the shadows.
And then... what the fuck is...
Oh, anti-Adeus!
Okay.
We're gonna do...
Best performance.
Or best quality.
Okay, we're gonna do...
Alright, and then I'm gonna change it back.
I'll put...
Put it at best quality.
And then that should be work, right?
Right, Todd?
Todd, please.
Let me see the game.
That's all I want.
I can't see the game!
I don't...
Oh, I know.
I know.
We're gonna listen to this intro like 20 times.
Guys.
I don't understand.
Okay, I'm gonna turn off window mode.
That has to be it.
What if I turn off borderless?
I'll turn off borderless and then I can just see it, right?
I just see the game, right?
Right?
Guys, I don't see the game.
Guys, I don't see the...
I don't understand.
Why can't I see the game?
I don't...
I don't understand.
Why don't I see the game?
Okay, I'm turning off window mode.
It has to be because I have window mode on.
That has to be it.
There's no other way.
There's no other reason.
I see it!
I see the game!
I did it, guys.
Thank you, Todd.
I knew it.
If you continue to believe in Todd, it'll work.
Alright.
This is it.
All you have to do is just believe in him.
I've always believed in him.
Alright.
Yay!
We're in Diamond City!
Yeah, dude!
His name is Codsworth!
Wait.
And Codman.
Well, hello there.
Another one of the poor and stupid of Diamond City come begging for paper scraps.
And I'm no human error.
There's too many people talking.
Poor and stupid?
I have you know I won Monopoly.
The poor and stupid?
Oh, don't act like you don't know.
There's two types of people in this town.
The ones living in the stands and everyone beneath us.
I know everyone in the stands and that doesn't include you.
Now, why don't you make yourself scarce?
Bitch.
What did you say?
That's right.
I'll do whatever.
I'm done talking to you.
What the fuck?
What if I kill her?
Is she that important?
How important is she?
Wait, give me a sec guys.
Uh, new save file?
Oh, she's important!
She's important!
Guys!
Okay, I should just accept my death.
Wow, I just woke up from a really bad dream guys.
Oh my god.
What a bad dream.
Who would have thought that she was important?
Wait, that's you!
Consworth 2!
24 hours?
You sell what?
What do you sell?
Uh, what do you sell?
Everything, mom!
We
also buy any unwanted items you may be carrying on your person.
They can buy stuff?
24 hours a day!
Whoa!
I wanna look.
Okay, can you buy my junk?
Which, I don't know what's junk.
Oh, that's junk, right?
One dollar.
That's one dollar?
This is like my life savings!
How can it be one dollar?
I don't understand!
Like, my entire life savings is in here!
I don't need your handouts.
If you don't want what is clearly worth so much money, then maybe you don't understand what worth is.
I don't know where to go.
Do I just explore Diamond City?
Hello?
The paper to newcomers.
If the Institute grabs you in the night, at least we warned you.
So, I'm just gonna go to Diamond City?
Wait, the Institute?
Institute?
You ain't heard of the Institute, lady?
They snatch people up in the night, and no one hears from them.
It's all in the paper.
What?
They get hurried up before they grab you, too.
Wait, who's missing?
Who's gone missing?
Oh, people who don't matter?
Seems every year or so.
Someone's gone.
And we all know why.
So you better be careful, newcomer.
The Institute is out there.
They don't matter.
That's... I...
That's... whatever.
That's nonsense.
You're just like that rich lady.
I'm looking for something.
I'm looking for a missing person.
I'm looking for my son.
My baby.
My son, lady?
Wow!
I hope the Institute takes you, too.
No one tries to find missing people in Diamond City.
Missing people means the Institute is involved.
And no one's going to want to get the Institute's attention.
Someone can help.
You're a smart kid.
Isn't there someone in town who's interested in this Institute?
I have the charisma.
I did have the charisma!
He's not afraid of anything.
Wait, Nick Valentine?
He was a Tumblr boy.
Wait.
What else do you know about Mr. Valentine?
People drew porn of him.
No one else won't admit it.
Ain't that the way it is?
No one's ever grateful for the people who help out the most.
That's not helpful.
Is that all you got, kid?
Hey, I already gave you a free paper, free advice, and a free recommendation to the detective agency.
My charity quota is...
Yeah, but I have a gun.
Wow!
God.
Who taught you this?
This is why you're an orphan.
Your parents didn't teach you anything because you don't have any.
I hope you...
You told me you meant to leave that rubbish where you found it.
Aww, what did I take?
I don't even remember what I took.
What was it?
The Institute sounds like a place with a bunch of nerds that need to get their lunch money taken.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't even know what I took.
It's okay.
What's Cosmo's gonna do?
Fucking leave me?
I literally bought him.
Okay, how do I...
Wait, I need to remember how...
Where's my... which one's my, like, melee?
Is it three?
Oh my god, I can't remember.
Okay, we're gonna...
Okay, I wanna grab...
Okay, we're gonna put this...
We're gonna put this, uh...
We're gonna go melee build.
Alright, ooh!
Let's see, oh there's the dragoon buster.
The knuckles, the fat is 30.
Okay, here we go.
Oh shit!
There's another Cogsworth.
What?!
Oh my god!
He called me poor!
How do you know I'm poor?
I live in suburbia!
What?!
How does he know I live in suburbia?
Also, sound guy, tell me in, like, in the chat, not in the Discord, about the sound.
I'll boost up the overall sound, by the way.
How did he know?!
Not interested.
I can't believe it.
Hey.
What?!
Oh my god, the robots are talking to each other.
Oh my god, they're talking to each other.
It's like talking to yourself.
Why are they, like, overlapping?
In volume!
Who let them speak?
They're flirting.
Where do I go?
I keep fucking accidentally want to break into people's houses.
Oh no, I actually got into a loading screen.
I tricked myself into a loading screen.
Hey, this is between me and my wife.
Why don't you mind your own damn business for once?
Oh god, Paul, why do you always have to make a scene?
Pour me another drink, Henry.
Damn it, Darcy, I just want you to come home.
I'll be home.
I can't believe you'd do this to me, cook.
Do what to you, Paul?
She's an alcoholic.
You keep away from my wife, god damn it.
You better get out of here.
Fight!
You son of a bitch.
I want to talk.
Oh, she's busy.
Go on.
Get out of here.
I'll be at home, Darcy.
What, did she lose?
Oh my god, she has a son?
Oh...
Want to talk now or she's still drinking?
Want to talk now?
Sorry I had to see that.
Things are usually a lot quieter around here.
Perfect place to drink if you're buying.
Wait, what's that argument about?
Yeah.
Nothing much.
You see, Darcy here likes to relax and enjoy life from time to time.
And her husband Paul doesn't.
He's not a bad guy, really.
Just a little uptight.
Too bad he can't learn to relax, huh, Darcy?
Shut up, I don't come here to talk about Paul.
You there!
I haven't seen you in here before.
Why don't you make yourself useful and buy me a drink or something?
Wait, buy you a drink?
Have a drink?
You know what?
Have a drink on me.
Drink away your problems.
Well, thank you very much.
I think you and I are going to get along just fine.
Free booze.
The fastest way to your home.
Wait, why is it over that?
What did I do?
Is it because of the...
How do I cap my FPS in game?
I try to provide a little oasis from the hardships.
I'm a good cook, by the way.
Henry Cook.
Let me know if I can get you anything.
Uh...
Maybe.
Not a problem.
Okay, we gotta fix this.
What the fuck happened?
Like everything...
Fuck.
How did everything got fucked up?
In one playthrough?
What did I do?
Okay, we're gonna save.
We're gonna save here.
This is it.
And then we're gonna quit to desktop.
And then we're gonna play window mode.
Window mode capped the FPS.
So maybe that's it.
It just works, guys.
You don't understand.
You never understand his vision.
Chat.
Okay, play.
Maybe it'll be better now.
I was like wondering.
I can see!
I can sing.
This is it.
See, I told you.
You always have to trust this...
Trust the process.
God.
We should give Todd more money.
Alright, there you go.
That should work, right?
I'm just gonna do third person.
I don't like how close...
I don't like how close they are to me.
Not interested.
I'll just up the volume.
If it's better now.
Wait, did I up the volume?
I actually forgot.
I up the volume for real this time.
Okay.
I just don't like how close they are to me.
First person hater?
I don't like...
I have a lack of personal space.
I need some personal space in between.
I don't like that.
I like it.
Fine, I'll do first person.
I actually don't know.
People are like...
I saw people that were like...
Wow, this is like the one...
Doki is one of the five people that plays in third person.
But it's so... everybody is so close to me.
I don't like it.
I feel like I don't have personal space.
I need like a buffer zone.
Yeah.
I need like a little buffer.
Alright, let's see.
Can I actually up the FOV?
I can't!
I can't even up the FOV!
You liars!
There's no way!
Yeah, I think the third person is cooler.
Wait, they're fighting again.
He's a synth?
Shoot him!
Do it!
Don't put the gun down!
Yeah!
I'm gonna loot him.
Yeah, there's no synths here.
I didn't do anything wrong.
What did you do?
What happened?
I looted before he fell over.
I didn't even listen to me.
That's what a synth will say.
I need a minute.
A synth is a robot, right?
Like an android?
Excuse me.
Also, I brought up the volume a little bit, sound guy.
God.
Wait, what did he wear?
Can I wear his item?
What did I... What was he wearing?
I'll be him.
Hahaha!
What was he wearing, guys?
I can be him for him.
Like...
Was he... Was it the hide outfit?
The newsboy cap?
I looted so fast that I couldn't even tell.
Oh, the newsboy cap and the padded blue jacket.
Don't worry, I'm him now.
Jesus.
Hahaha!
Everyone's still standing around for you.
Why not?
I'll be your brother for you.
I'll be fine.
Hahaha!
I looted so fast that I don't even know.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we need that.
And then we need the raider chest piece.
And then... Is that good?
Nice.
Alright.
Now I look...
Oh no, I need to take off the hat.
No hat.
Alright.
Where's like...
Uh... Nick Valentine.
Where's his place?
Diamond City...
Diamond City Market...
How do I find...
Local map?
Is this the local map?
Whoa.
Where's...
Where does Nick Valentine go?
Do you live here?
No, that's the basement.
It's in the alleyway.
It's in the alleyway?
There's so many alleys.
Which one's the right alley?
Is this an alley?
That's a school.
Oh, there it is!
Detective!
It has to be in the greenhouse.
Road to Freedom?
Is this not the alleyway?
I'll grab some of this.
Ooh!
I got some fruit though.
Wrong house!
I don't know.
I thought they would...
He would be here.
I thought he'd just chill in the greenhouse.
Oh, it's the next door?
Yeah, but it says detective!
Oh no.
I'm stuck in the loading screen again.
I think that's like the worst part about Fallout 4.
The loading screen.
The fucking loading screen, man.
It's so long!
Okay.
Alright, it is...
It's this way.
It's down this alley.
Valentine!
Detective Agency!
There he is!
Uh...
Where is he?
I'm here for the detective.
Hello?
You're too late!
Why?
It's important.
Me and my two charisma is gonna...
charm you.
No!
I can't believe any clues!
I need to find this Tumblerman!
What the fuck is getting him alone?
I don't have failed Riz.
They're just not into me.
I want money.
Oh that works!?
I want more.
Oh boy.
Yeah, this is your fucking boss.
Don't you love him?
What?
It's gonna be a hundred now?
No!
How could this happen to me?
But if it says good neighbor, that means he's like a good neighbor.
Right?
What does that mean?
But it says good.
The greedy gets punished?
That can't be.
I balanced it out.
Contours didn't like it and then he liked it again.
Alright, that's our first quest.
We're gonna save Nick Valentine.
Is there anything I can borrow?
This.
There we go.
Nice.
I can borrow this.
Alright.
Alright, come on Cogsworth.
We're gonna go save your kind.
One of your kind.
Don't say I'm... Don't say I'm racist against synths now.
I'm literally saving your kind, Cogsworth.
Monopoly changed me.
I felt the power.
Alright, back to the loading screen we go.
Okay, we gotta save Nick Valentine.
I got a bat for it.
Okay.
Wait, what's the difference between a synth and a robot?
Aren't they the same?
Or is it like an android thing?
Are synths androids?
Okay, good neighbor.
Is it here?
You're gonna discover... Okay.
He's in the good neighbor area.
Whoa!
Guys, did you know you can do this?
I can like move my...
I can move my arms like a real person.
Whoa!
Okay.
Uh...
Is that it?
Oh, they're androids.
Oh, so they're like part...
Uh...
So they're part human.
Oh!
Okay.
I guess like...
Talk to the settlers at...
We're gonna let the settlement die, I guess.
They're only 22% happy?
Well, sucks to be them.
Fucking...
I guess they'll be depressed then.
Join the club.
All right, we're gonna go.
Oh no, that's cyborg.
Wait, then what's the difference between and...
What's...
Wait, then what's...
Androids.
You cause trouble.
There's gonna be trouble.
I can't believe you eat that.
Are androids...
Oh, androids does look like humans, right?
And that's the bullshit.
Androids are synths, so they are not actually human, but they just look like humans.
Yeah, so they are robots.
Then he is the same.
Comptor is just less evolved.
I don't know.
Yeah, they're robots then.
I can't believe it.
You guys were like, no, Doki, can't believe you would say that, but the androids are practically robots.
They're just synthetic humans.
Exactly.
So he's basically...
He's basically like, like Cogsworth except he has legs.
And Cogsworth doesn't.
Yeah.
Yeah, Codsworth is like the missing link in robot evolution.
Alright, we gotta go find...
Where's my marker?
Oh my god, where's my marker?
I gotta remember how to read the map.
First goal, remembering how to read the map.
Do robots have rights?
Of course not!
And they'll never have rights!
As long as I'm in charge!
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Did I not mark it?
I thought I did.
Okay, mark unlikely...
Yeah, I marked it here.
And then...
Oh, it's right here.
Okay.
Woo!
Dang!
Bad dog!
Okay, there you go.
We're fine.
Uuuuuh...
It's this way.
Uh, wait.
No, it's not this way.
Oh no.
Doki is lost.
Codsworth, if you wanna start having rights, tell me where to go.
Wait, are they good people?
THEY'RE NOT GOOD PEOPLE!
CODSWORTH, GO!
GO CODSWORTH!
That's right!
Do your thing!
Oh my god!
It's okay.
I can outback you.
I got him.
I put it all on strength.
It's okay!
I put it all on strength!
Alright, fuck the strength build!
Nevermind!
What the fuck!
They're super mutants!
Guys, remember I was like, it would be funny to go get you a strength build?
Wait, I'm back here?
Okay guys, I'm getting a gun.
Guys, I know my place now.
I've always been a gunslinger.
I'm poking it in smash.
I got up at it.
Guys, I figured it out.
I feel like I was just not meant to hold.
I was just not meant to smash.
ArkHero4Androids vs Cyports is giving flashbacks to my Dragon Ball Z fanboy.
Fanboy, they shake my head.
They give the super chat.
Thank you.
Where did all these security people go when I needed them the most?
That's so fucked up.
Okay, it's this way.
The moment I needed them, they were gone.
It's alright.
Now I have...
Now I have guns.
So there's no way I can lose.
Wait, who's that?
There, see?
There's no way I can lose now.
I have guns.
There you go.
What the fuck?
He's not glowing.
It's like he doesn't have yellow paint.
Oh, there's stuff.
There's stuff I love.
God damn, I keep sitting down.
It was just a free massage until the super mutants attacked.
Saying thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe there were super mutants.
They didn't trade me for this.
Oh, the public library.
Alright, we go this way.
Like, where did they come from?
Where did they go?
They're gone now.
Alright, guys.
It's okay, it's an investment.
I'll invest in...
Wait, are they bad people?
Wait, they're mannequins.
Why are there naked mannequins there?
Are they naked?
Oh shit.
Somebody got really lonely.
Alright, we go this way.
I'm gonna go to the car.
Down here.
Did you hear that?
Cosworth, did you hear that?
There's a person here!
Cosworth, go!
Go, Cosworth!
They shot a gun!
It's a psycho!
Nice.
See, assault, assault, raid...
Okay, here we go.
Nice.
Nice, free loot.
Free fucking loot.
I love free loot.
Get over here, Cosworth.
Go, Cosworth, go!
Alright, this way.
Am I close?
Where am I?
Oh, I am close!
It's like, literally like...
next door.
Ah, this way.
It's like 60...
meters away.
Cosworth, we're gonna replace you.
Oh!
I can never tell if it's water!
Everything is just brown and black!
Like, how can I tell if it's water?
It blends in!
Oh, shit.
How is this radiation?
I say as I look at the fucking barrels of radiation.
I can't believe it.
How can that be radiation?
Oh, I love all the stuff.
Oh, shut up!
Oh, Nuka Cola?
There's no Nuka Cola.
For Nuka Cola.
How do I get in here?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, shoot the water?
Why should I shoot the water?
This one?
Guys, don't shoot the water.
Guys, guys, loading screen!
Loading screen!
Someone prepped the boss music.
It's okay.
Jesus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay, I got saved by the loading screen.
It's okay.
The loading screen saved.
I got clutched.
The water was slightly angry at me.
It's okay.
He'll go back into the water after, right?
Right?
He's gonna go back to the water, right guys?
It's like nothing bad happened.
Chat.
It's like I didn't do anything wrong.
See, look at that.
We're safe, Cogsworth.
We did it!
We're safe!
What the fuck is...
Skinny Man?
Oh yeah, Skinny Malone.
We caught that detective snooping around.
And what does he do?
Whoa!
How did you see me?
It's okay, Cogsworth.
Go do your thing.
I'm gonna watch.
Go, Cogsworth.
Go!
Shoot him!
Yeah, it's just a scratch.
Do your thing.
Go, go!
He's over there.
Go!
Yeah, that's right!
Yeah!
You do your thing, Cogsworth!
Body block for me!
I don't need a user.
I don't need to use VATS if I have pure aim.
Look at that.
Wait, what the fuck?
Am I getting shot from the back?
It's okay.
We're okay.
I don't remember how to heal.
Guys, how do I heal?
What was the heal button?
Three.
Guys, it was not three.
I got the baton.
Oh no, I don't remember which one was heal.
Do I not have heals?
Cogsworth, please.
Please body block.
I have to remember how to heal.
Aide.
Okay.
Do I give radiation with this?
That should be fine, right?
We're fine.
See?
Go body block.
Oh, he's not fine.
There you go.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
We're okay, guys.
Cogsworth, get up!
I'll shoot him in the dick for you!
We're okay.
Everything's fine.
Oh, that's radiated?
Oh!
Okay.
It's fine, everybody.
I can shoot him in the arm.
No.
Okay.
That...
He can shoot through the walls, but I can't?
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit going in.
There you go.
We're okay.
Nothing is...
Nothing bad is gonna happen, guys.
Look!
See?
He's fine!
We actually gotta, like, inspect.
Plus one rad.
Okay.
No, we don't need the rad.
How the fuck?
Oh, there it is.
There's the rad.
Okay.
Minus one intelligence.
Plus one strength.
Two rad.
When do I not get rad?
Okay.
Two rad.
Oh!
Nuka cherry!
That's like five rad.
I can take that risk.
That's a risk I'm willing to take.
I'm gonna take your stuff.
I'm gonna take yours.
Then...
I'm gonna take all the junk as well.
Oh shit!
Money!
Look, everything's fine.
Okay.
We can pick this.
Uh...
Is it A?
Okay.
Now...
Yeah!
First try!
Oh my god!
And money?
It's my birthday!
And a bucket?
Wait, I think that's purified water, was it?
Okay.
Alright.
Cogsworth, I need you to do something.
Cogsworth, get over here.
Alright.
Trade.
I need you to hold my stuff.
Um...
Let's see.
I need to do...
Uh... sort...
What's this?
Bottle cap mine?
Why would I need a mine if I can just...
Okay.
Three...
Weight zero... weight twelve point six.
This has to be...
Okay.
We're gonna put away...
Extinguisher.
Okay.
We're gonna put away that.
We're gonna put away this.
We're gonna start...
No!
I need my gun!
Oh no.
I put away...
my gun, guys.
Oh no.
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
We have other guns.
We have so many other guns, guys.
We'll be fine.
Okay.
And then...
You hold all of these.
You can't carry more?
What's the point if you can't keep carrying stuff?
What's the point?
Oh shit.
Okay.
We need to...
I don't even know what I'm holding on to anymore.
There's too many things.
Guys, I'm like...
Guys, I think I have a hoarding problem.
Guys, I'm not sure yet.
But I think I have a small issue.
Just a little bit of an issue.
Wait.
Can I upgrade stuff now?
Oh, I can!
Alright.
What do we do?
Guys, someone said I should do Idiot Savant.
Did she revert to Self-Archer Sniper yet?
Thank you for the switch at Platypus.
Thank you.
Where's Idiot Savant?
Where is that?
Am I dumb enough?
Luck?
Where is it?
Do I just need to do Luck more?
In the Luck Tree?
Okay.
Idiot Savant.
Mystery.
Oh, there you go.
I need 5 Luck.
Okay.
We gotta invest in Luck, guys.
Alright.
Nice.
What is Idiot Savant?
Everyone keeps telling me to do it.
You're not stupid.
Just...
Guys!
I'm not stupid!
See?
Even the game doesn't think I'm stupid.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I wasn't stupid.
The game was right.
Alright.
Here we go.
Just different.
You guys just don't understand.
Alright.
Loot.
Hello?
Oh!
This is a terrible gun!
Okay.
This gun was terrible.
Alright.
We're gonna do pistol.
Pistol was the key.
It's always the key.
Alright.
Let me eat.
Guys, it's okay if I get a little bit of radiation.
Uh...
Nuka Cola.
Oh my god.
It's full HP.
That's good.
Where is he?
See?
Look!
It's so much easier!
Alright.
Go Cosworth!
Go!
I can actually headshot!
Oh my god!
Why do they have actual guns?
And I have a fucking BB gun!
They give real guns and I'm shooting a fucking BB gun!
I shoot his foot.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Guys, it's gonna be okay.
It's gonna be okay.
Cosworth is taking everything for me.
Which one was fast again?
Guys, I don't remember!
Cosworth, please!
Okay.
Cute.
Alright.
Okay.
Cute.
Alright.
Okay.
I got it.
I'm gonna shoot them in the head.
I have to eventually hit that, right?
Boom.
There!
I did it!
Oh!
I'm a fucking natural!
Oh my god!
BB gun is fine if I can hit all these shots.
I don't know where I'm getting shot at.
It's okay.
No!
It's not okay!
Cosworth, please!
Oh!
Stop coming back and help me!
Oh my god.
Just stop coming back!
Just go for it!
Oh my god.
Just stop coming back!
Oh god.
Okay.
Head, head, head.
Eventually I'll hit the head.
Please!
I just need...
COSWORTH, YOU'RE BLOCKING THE BULLET!
NO!
He blocked the bullet!
He actually...
He actually blocked all the bullets!
Hey, Cosworth, you fucking idiot!
He fucking blocked it!
Oh my god.
COSWORTH!
I don't ask for much, Cosworth.
I actually don't!
Oh my god.
He actually blocked me!
That's actually crazy!
Holy shit.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he blocked me like that.
Oh, I got reloaded.
I was so ready to shoot my gun.
Oh my god.
No, no.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I was so ready to...
He lives that?
Bro, that's some fucking helmet.
No!
Oh my god.
Alright, we gotta try out some guns real quick.
Wait, what about the pipe?
No, pipe pistol was the fucking shitty one.
Oh my god.
It's back to the BB gun.
Hahaha!
Back to the BB gun, guys.
There you go.
Hahaha!
Okay, there you go.
Nice.
I have aim.
It's okay.
Is that ghoul?
That's a ghoul right there.
Give me your gun.
.45.
I'm gonna take that.
That has to be a good gun, right?
.45?
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
Where's your gun?
What gun did you have?
Oh no.
I don't know what gun he had.
He's dead now.
Alright.
Okay.
He has to get closer.
Right?
Oh, he also has a 10mm!
Wow!
Okay, fuck this.
Hahaha!
The 10mm has been the clutch this entire time!
A little bit of red!
It's okay!
I need it!
Guys, I tried the strength build.
And like, I need more.
Okay, like, it's too difficult to do strength right now.
Hahaha!
We gotta like...
Guys, the reason why we're not doing strength yet, guys.
Is that...
Is that we don't...
We don't have like...
I don't have stimpacks, guys.
The only reason why we can't do strength build is that we haven't invested properly in strength yet.
So like...
There's nothing we can do!
I need more armor to focus on strength!
We don't have the investments yet, guys!
Like, we're so weak!
I'm just gonna rob...
Oh no, Cogsworth, I need help!
Cogsworth, I took too many items!
Cogsworth, we're so poor!
Hahaha!
Cogsworth, I fucked...
Where is he?!
Oh, why am I taking more items?
Cogsworth, I need you!
Cogsworth, I need you to hold on to my stuff for me!
Hahaha!
I fucked up again!
Cogsworth, I fucked up!
I took too many things!
Okay, we gotta drop...
Okay, we don't need all of these.
Okay, pipe pistol.
Okay, pipe auto pistol.
But 10 mm is just so much better.
Okay, we don't need 6, 7, 10 mm's.
Alright, guys, we don't need all of that.
I can't help it!
I can't help it, guys!
I just wanna keep looting!
Do I have enough?
Okay, there we go.
Guys, I managed to...
I managed to like drop some stuff.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is my robot butler?
This is exactly why they don't...
The robots don't deserve any rights.
Holy shit.
They can't even do a simple job as to follow me.
I will never drop the pipe bombs.
Wait, can I drop the...
What is the pipe bomb?
This one?
Where is the pipe bomb?
Oh my god, grenades.
Harsh but true.
Bro, he's not even following me!
Where is he?
Like, literally, where is my fucking robot?
Wait, what's this?
Is this the outside?
Oh, I'm outside now.
I went the wrong way.
God's worth has better things to do.
I actually went outside.
I'm trying to save Valentine!
All pipe guns are bad to me.
But that means I can save...
I can sell it.
It takes a thousand rats to kill you.
That was driving me nuts.
I had to message to say that.
Also, the submachine gun is terrible.
Thank you for the super chat.
There you are, Cogsworth!
Oh my god.
First, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But then I can sell it.
I can sell...
I can sell like the...
He's so sick of me that he...
Bro!
If he's sick of me using it as a mission...
Then do something!
He can stop this if he does anything.
Okay, he did something.
He ran away.
I can't do a melee build yet!
I can't do it yet!
I don't...
I need a...
I'm too weak!
If I get close, I get shot at by 20 people!
I'm too weak right now!
That was a skill issue.
Not enough insurance.
I need more!
10 is not enough!
I need like 50!
Holy shit, this loading screen!
Fallout 4, please!
I heard that you can mod it in a way that reduces the loading time.
Is that true?
All I hear is wah, wah, wah.
Just skill issue.
The world needs more.
We need more.
Oh my god.
There is?
Okay, we're gonna figure this out next time.
Because I can't.
Holy shit, that takes fucking forever.
Am I going the right way to saving him?
Like, where is he?
It says here.
Bye Nick.
Is Nick here?
I'm not nothing.
Oh god, oh god, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, while I fucking eat.
Go Cosworth, I need to find food that gives me the most... oh there you go.
Purified water.
Oh, there you go.
Alright, go Cosworth, go.
Over there!
Oh god, oh god.
Oh god.
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, here, here!
Hit, hit, hit, hit, hit!
Guys, I think it's a bad idea that I'm in the open, guys.
Like...
Guys, I think... I don't think I should be in the open, everybody.
Yeah!
I'm having a lot of fun!
No!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
He's actually doing something.
I'm gonna run.
There's no way he can shoot me.
Okay.
Head, head, head, head.
There's... I have to hit it.
Nope.
Almost.
No, almost there.
Nope!
Oh!
That 20% should not have taken that 20% bet.
It's okay.
I can shoot it myself, I guess.
Guys, guys, okay.
I did it.
Guys, I should not have taken that 20% bet.
Yeah, it's...
The 20% bet was not in my favor.
Maybe I'm faster than a bullet.
You guys don't know that.
I did it.
Okay.
Fine!
I'll play first person!
Alright, what's in Vault 114?
Yay!
Yeah, it's me.
That's me.
A good person?
Oh!
Nice.
We're okay.
Oh my god!
He has a bat!
He's going full melee!
Braver than me.
He truly is braver than me.
Okay, I should stop taking people's clothes.
I really should.
But I can't help it.
Oh, he has potato crisp!
Alright.
Guys, I restrained myself from taking his clothes, guys.
Guys, I did it.
Guys, are you proud of me?
I didn't... I didn't take his clothes, guys.
I actually did it.
Alright, gotta eat some bubble gum.
Maybe a corn.
Maybe some cram.
There you go.
I'll take the vegetable starch, though.
There's a sliding door.
Oh, I can open the door!
Open.
I did it, guys!
I let him have his clothes on!
Ooh, purified water.
We need that.
Hello?
Is anybody here?
I'm a good person!
Hello?
Nick?
So I got a question.
Why the hell would anyone build a vault out of a subway station?
This place is like the opposite of a gas station.
Oh!
Did people like mutate it?
That's a ghoul!
Oh!
They weren't planning on using it?
I thought it was like a way to like...
I thought it was like a way...
Okay, that's that.
I'm gonna take my gacha.
I know it's gonna work.
I knew it!
It hit, guys!
Oh!
Oh my god, 100 crit!
My gacha was good today.
My gacha was good to me.
There, nice.
I don't have to...
Oh shit, okay.
Wait!
Did you see that?
That's a better gun!
Glow-sided hair trigger.
Oh my god!
It's radioactive!
Instant mash, 10 mm pistols.
No, I'm carrying too much again!
I have a problem!
I have a hoarder problem!
I...
I have a problem!
There we go.
We got this.
I should eat to aid.
I'll eat some...
You know what?
I'll eat some instant mash.
And some dog meat.
I'll find a right away later.
Right?
I'm gonna find right away.
Wait, what the fuck?
Peek me!
Wait, if I go closer...
I have faster fingers!
Oh shit!
That wasn't it.
Sorry.
I thought I could like out-shoot him.
No!
Every time!
Every fucking time!
I keep taking more and more stuff!
Okay, we gotta drop this.
We gotta drop all these machine guns.
Okay, here we go.
I should be fine now.
Ooh, double egg!
So...
Nice.
Alright, it's this way.
No, I need all these junk!
You don't understand!
You don't understand, dragons!
Oh shit!
The fastest fingers!
Oh my god, they have an oven mitt!
Hello?
No, you don't.
Oh wait, duct tape.
Ball peen hammer?
What's that?
Shock glass, whiskey...
Pre-war money?
What can I do with pre-war money?
We'll drop them off at our settlement later after we find Nick.
Who's that?
Who's that over here?
I hear somebody!
Okay.
I gotta loosen up.
I got the fidgets.
It won't look up, right?
No!
Cosworth!
You bitch!
Cosworth actually pushed me!
Oh my god!
He actually pushed me down!
Oh my god, you bitch!
Okay, I know Nick Valentine.
He has...
Oh no, I'm fucking in Coomberwood again.
No!
Oh my god, look at my collection of guns here!
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna not take that submachine gun.
Alright, this should be it, right?
I found you?
I found him?
The circuit rush kicked in.
I know he can carry my stuff.
I gave him all my stuff now.
So he has everything.
I found a loading screen.
No!
I found a loading...
This is the only thing that's killing me right now.
Playing Fallout 4.
It's the goddamn loading screen.
Someone fucking linked me the mod in Bird Cedars later after the stream where I could fucking at least have the time of...
...of the loading screen.
I can't.
I actually can't.
I can't take this.
It's actually fucking me up, man.
Alright.
Oh!
Look at the lights.
The settlement needs some flashlights.
Get him!
Alright.
No, 4%...
You know what?
I'll take the 4%.
No, fuck.
It's at 0% now.
I'll be fine.
It's just one guy.
I can kill one guy.
Get over here.
There you go.
Pew!
Oh my god!
I might as well shoot him myself.
Bro!
Like, I shot... Bro!
I don't need the VAT system.
I might as well shoot him myself.
It was just... It was just faster.
It was actually just faster.
Hello?
I don't know who you are, but we got 3 minutes.
I did it.
Before they realize muscles for brains ain't coming back.
Get this door open!
How do I get it open?
I'm trying to.
Did I not pick up the overseer?
You're gonna hack that terminal to open up this door.
There's a terminal?
Oh, there you are!
Oh, there's a terminal right here!
I got you.
I'm so good at hacking.
Alright.
Password required.
Brains vault system.
Oh, override.
Please take a number.
Okay.
Please wait until your number is called.
Have a nice day.
Oh, I can override.
Joki, the loading gets better if you turn off the V-Sync.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Did I turn off V-Sync?
I don't know.
Okay.
I did.
Opening door.
Nice.
Okay.
I did it!
Hello?
You're the one that everybody likes.
I don't understand.
I'm trying to track a murderer.
Yeah!
I don't usually go after blood money, but I guess I can make an exception.
I've been cooped up in here for weeks.
Turns out the runaway daughter I came here to find wasn't kidnapped.
She's Skinny Malone's new flame.
Oh!
He got baited.
Anyway, you got troubles and I'm glad to help.
But now ain't the time.
Let's blow this joint.
Then we'll talk.
Is he going to be my new companion?
There we go.
Oh!
I'll take it.
Malone's crew here used to be small time.
Muscled out of the old...
What's this?
Welcome, employees.
I hope this mistress find you well and you move into your new position.
Your appointment as Overshare came with high recommendation from our interviewers.
Please do not be nervous.
Oh, that's it?
Okay.
...by bigger players.
That's it.
I want to take these.
...to the previous owners, but they're not exactly around the job.
Oh, I take these.
Please, please, please!
Can we just run back to town?
Do I...?
Do I have to follow him?
Can I just...
...fast travel back to Diamond City?
Hold
up.
I hear some of them coming.
There they are.
Where?
How do you wanna play this?
Shoot him... Nick.
Let's keep moving.
We'll talk once we're out.
Nek, Dino!
Shoot him!
I'm ready to shoot him!
Wait, listen to the tapes?
Which tape did I grab?
I move so fast, I never...
I don't know.
Muns, ammo, junk...
Where is it?
Was it this one?
Was it 21?
Or...
21 or 103?
21?
Are you just gonna walk back?
There you
go.
Red Axe!
Oh my god, they just stopped her interview.
Yeah, she just started!
She talked too much.
They don't like it.
They don't like it when they talk too much.
They just wanna be obedient.
Oh!
Food!
I always need more food.
Yeah, they're not looking for someone competent.
They're looking for people like me.
She... he can...
Hell of a lot easier to do.
Wait, he can hack!
Oh my god, he can hack!
He's already better than Cogsworth.
I need these wrenches.
I don't know what I'm gonna do with them, but I know I need it.
There's a nursery?
Me?
It's me!
Doki!
Oh,
I need these.
I don't know what I'm gonna do with it, but I need them.
Shoot him!
Just shoot him!
Oh, I need that too.
And I need that.
Oh, I definitely need this.
It's a comic book.
Cogsworth is useless.
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
Uh...
This way?
Yeah!
Oh, no, no, not this way.
Oh.
Like this?
No!
My bobby pin!
It's okay, I have a lot.
I have a lot.
No.
Oh.
Should be like here.
No.
Like this?
I know we're in the middle of a gunfight right now, but I need to figure this out.
Yes.
Yay!
What is that?
Soap?
Oh, it's soap.
Look at all this soap!
And melons!
And beer!
Oh my god!
The settlement needs...
Needs...
Needs a broom.
Oh, I need a broom.
My bread!
All right, I can eat now!
Let's see.
I picked up so much food!
I must be able to eat now.
All right, I can get...
Oh, but that's two rads!
Is there anything that gives me a lot?
Purified water?
I guess I'll take the purified water.
Oh, wait!
I'm still...
I forgot to do the one thing!
It's okay.
Uh, I mean, I don't need seven hats, I guess.
Do I?
What?
Do I...
Guys, I guess I don't need seven fedoras.
I guess.
Alright, here we go.
I should have enough right.
Here we go.
What's that?
Iguana on a stick?
Oh, he has a black baseball bat though.
Will he be fine?
Can Nick Valentine die?
Not that it's an option.
He'll be fine, right?
Oh, I need an empty can.
No!
But I need all of this!
If only you could wear all six.
Okay, I guess I don't need this.
I guess I don't need six suits.
I guess.
Wait, I need one of these for armor.
Okay, I don't need the left arm.
I'm too lazy.
What's that?
Wonder glue?
Oh my god, we always need glue.
Oh shit.
There you go.
I honestly don't know if they actually have...
Oh my god!
A melon?
I need a melon!
A pillow!
The settlement needs more pillows!
Oh my god, I need all these plates.
Guys, you don't understand.
These plates are so annoying.
They're so important.
You don't understand, guys.
Alright, I can get rid of like...
I'll get... Okay, fine.
I'll get rid of like...
I'll get rid of the plates, okay?
I'll get rid of the plates.
But I'm keeping the pillow.
I don't have a problem!
They're important!
Oh my god, we need...
I was busy looking at the cigarette!
Did you hear the Lord drop the husband being a war criminal?
Jim, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, I know he was in the war.
I didn't realize he was a war criminal.
Okay, I'll eat the melon.
I'll eat it.
And I guess I'll eat the...
I'll just have profile water.
It's okay.
He can't die, right?
Okay.
Whoa, he's so tanky!
There you go.
Alright, bottle cap.
And then I'll grab the bottle cap.
And then the rounds.
Oh my god, can I steal the bike?
Guys, I don't... I swear...
The toy car!
A toy truck before my toy car!
Guys!
I need all of this!
What else do they have?
A Vault-Tec lab coat?
Wait, you can't romance Nick Valentine?
I thought you could.
Then why the fuck is everybody freaking out about Nick Valentine?
Nick Valentine...
I don't have a problem!
Oh my god!
A Vault-Tec...
...jumpsuit!
We need that.
Look at these lights.
I can't do...
It's okay.
It'll be fine.
Alright, it's fine.
Iguana stick?
What the fuck is an iguana stick?
Oh, I guess it... Oh, it's a Oh, it's an iguana on a stick.
I know what an iguana stick is now.
Alright guys, I'm gonna eat a little bit.
Let's see, and then...
We'll eat the fruit.
Guys, it's okay.
Just a little bit of it.
I should get rid of some stuff.
No!
But what about my...
Okay, maybe I don't need all of that.
Fine, I'll get rid of this.
Open the door, Nick.
Open it.
Where did he go?
Oh, he went outside.
He disappeared!
Where did he go?
You save those fruits for your settlement?
They don't need it!
What is gonna happen to my settlement?
They'll die?
They'll starve?
There's no way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They'll be fine.
They'll just need more plates.
Guys, it'll be fine.
I'll just give them plates.
They can just grow more.
Exactly.
I don't need those fruits.
Wait, they can leave?
They'll leave my settlement?
You mean I actually have to care?
Wait, how much fruits do I have left?
Do I still have fruits?
I still have fruits.
I still have the...
the muti-fruits and the double eggs.
Guys, I still have fruits.
How much this is gonna set me back?
I wouldn't be here if it weren't for your two timing game, Skinny.
You oughta tell her to write home more often.
Oh, poor little Valentine.
Ashamed you got beat up by a girl?
I'll just run back home to Daddy.
They can't be planted?
That's it?
I'm gonna kill him.
Oh no guys.
Wait, I have a nade, right?
I do.
I should have a nade.
I've hoarded so much, I must have one nade.
Oh nice, I do.
Alright.
How do I take my nade out?
Guys, how do I take my nade out?
You can just look at it.
Is it G?
Oh, it's M4.
Encourage violence.
Wait, what's going on for her?
I actually wanna know the lore.
Turns out she skipped town to be with my old pal Skinny Malone.
Mob boss.
Never thought he'd manage to scrape together a big enough crew to take over a vault.
Guess life's full of surprises.
Hey, who's running this show here?
You got something to say?
Say it to me.
Darla's the problem.
Listen to me, I'm hotter than her.
Look at yourself.
Darla is playing you for a sap.
I have red hair.
You're better than her.
You're right.
Oh my god, I'm right!
She walked into my life.
What are you talking about?
I knew it, killer!
She's saying you're dragging me and this whole operation down a bad road.
I told you.
It's true.
It works because I'm a woman.
I'm a real female.
Fat ass.
They always gotta hit you where it hurts.
Now what am I gonna do about you two?
Skinny Malone is not skinny.
That sucks, bro.
I still see your ugly faces after that.
I'm gonna start shooting until there ain't no more bullets left in this whole vault.
We better get out of here fast.
I fucking did it.
I knew it.
Two.
Oh shit!
Oh, he's counting!
He knows how to count!
Where do I go?
I go here?
Valentine!
Where do I go?
Wait, where did he go?
Why is he taking you forever?
Kongsworth, why are you over there?
Don't worry.
No, I did call.
He has all my inventory right now.
Are you gonna leave?
I'll leave first.
I didn't know which exit they're gonna take.
There's so many exits.
It's okay.
I have Nick Valentine now.
I have to actually work on my settlement?
This is such a scam.
Why can't it be automated?
I don't understand.
Why do I have to work on the settlement?
Is that fair?
Just let them leave.
Well, baby.
If it's me having a fucking house...
I have to work for it.
It's so cruel.
Where is the...
Dragoons at the sanctuary.
Where is the food?
I don't know, Dragoons.
I'm eating all the fucking red roach meat.
Get your own food, Dragoons.
Farm your own food.
Why are you depending on me?
I barely can take care of myself.
Oh my god.
It's still loading.
Please.
Somebody link me that mod so I can patch it later before part 3.
50% of this playthrough is just loading screens.
Three years later.
Wait, are Cogsworth and Nick the same voice actor?
Wait, they're really the same?
I didn't realize.
We're going to die.
Just eat the egg goons.
Just make them the food.
We have the tomato goons and the egg goons.
Just eat them.
It's fresh meat.
That's why survival of the fittest.
It just works.
The loading screen simulator.
Doki, please.
We're so hungry.
Look at the dragons.
It's fine.
Calibism is fine.
If it's for survival.
I don't have enough space in my SSD.
My SSD only has the important games.
Like Apex and Overwatch.
Father, please.
It's time.
Do I need to start praying to time?
Oh, holy time.
Please let me play the game.
All I want to do is go to Diamond City.
So I can make Nick my companion.
Because I'm pretty sure he's a better companion than Cogsworth.
Please.
That's all I want.
I spent the majority of this game in this black screen.
Time.
Oh, thank God.
Can I turn Vsync off here?
All right.
Vibration.
I don't think that's Vsync.
No, I cannot.
All right.
I guess we suffer.
I'm going to play the game.
Where do we go?
Where do we go now?
Ellie.
She sent me.
My son.
Oh, okay.
I'll meet you there.
Yeah.
I'll see you in Diamond City.
I saved Valentine.
Yeah.
I did it.
Okay.
We're going to...
Oh, I leveled up.
Hey.
I leveled up.
All right, guys.
I need more luck apparently.
Right?
I need more luck.
All right.
I need like five luck.
I have three luck now.
Nice.
Okay.
All right.
We're going to travel to...
I'm going to go to the next one.
Our sanctuary so we can like throw some shit away.
Where's my house?
Here?
Oh, sanctuary.
Oh, they're 24% happy.
Look, they did it.
All right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki has such a huge muscle.
Why not run?
Use melee weapons or punch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Well, you see, we tried that and then I got shot by 20 people.
So I realized I shouldn't try that.
All right.
After getting shot by 20 people, it was just not it.
It was not it.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Now that I threw all of that away.
Where's Cogsworth?
Cogsworth, I know you have items.
Trade.
Okay.
Give me back all...
Yes.
I'll take it all up.
And then I'm going to transfer.
And then I'm going to go to the next one.
I'm going to press store all junk.
And...
Yeah.
I dumped all the junk.
That's the junk, right?
I did it.
Okay.
Cogsworth, I need to transfer some stuff.
Wait there.
Okay.
And then I'm going to throw some stuff away.
You know what?
Just take some...
Just take...
Do you know what?
Fuck it.
Just take this.
Wait.
No.
Don't take that.
Take...
I don't know.
I don't need all these fusion cells.
What are the fusion cells for?
Anyway.
Okay.
We're going to put the heavy stuff.
Uh...
Let's see.
Wait 20.
Oh my God.
No.
Take these.
What the fuck am I talking about?
Take all of that.
That's way too much inventory.
Uh...
And then I'll throw away...
I'll keep all of these for now.
I'm going to start selling stuff.
Oh, it's ammo?
Oh.
Okay.
Can I build stuff now?
Okay, guys.
We're going to figure this out.
Okay.
We're going to move this.
How do I move this?
No.
That's not it.
How do I move you?
Um...
Select.
Oh.
Whoa.
Okay.
And then...
And then I'll put you here.
And then we put you here.
Attach wires.
Wait.
Can I attach it to the water pipe?
Does the water pipe need water...
Need electricity?
That's stupid, Dookie.
Why did you say that?
D.
Are you...
Is the D on now?
Is it...
Is the D...
Oh, the D lights up!
The dark light is on!
Oh, my God!
The D lights up!
It lights up!
I did it!
Right?
I can't tell.
Is there another thing to hold the wire?
How would I...
Oh.
I did it.
Yay!
I did it!
Oh, my God.
I'm so good at this.
All right.
Now we need food.
Guys.
I'm so hungry.
We need food now.
Resources.
Okay.
Food.
Wait.
I have carrots!
I can...
I can give them carrots!
And corn!
Oh, my God.
This is it.
I have...
Okay.
Good.
Guys!
I'm feeding my...
I'm doing it!
I knew it!
I knew I could feed them!
I'm doing it!
Oh, my God.
I fucking knew it!
I knew I could feed them!
You guys didn't believe me at first.
It was like, oh, Doki.
Your people are going to fucking starve.
I was like, no.
No, they're not.
They'll be fine.
There's no way they can starve under my rule.
Okay.
And then...
Uh...
And I have...
I have grain!
They're going to be so wealthy!
I'm fed!
Look!
We did it!
Okay.
And then water.
Do we need more water?
Why do you need more water?
Okay.
I guess we'll put two pumps.
We'll put another pump here.
Yeah.
Now you guys are fine.
Yeah!
We have to tell people to work the food?
Work on the fucking...
Wait.
No.
They're already assigned.
These guys are already assigned.
Chat.
They're already automatically assigned.
Okay.
I did good.
I did good, guys.
My people are happy now.
See?
My people are happy.
We did it, Cogsworth!
We fucking did it!
All right.
We can...
Finally...
We don't have to care anymore.
Fucking finally.
Yes.
I do.
It's okay.
We have the...
We got the minute man to defend our place.
If it gets raided, at least the minute man can defend it, right?
That's the point, right?
My job here is done.
Oh my god, it's the morning!
I gotta sell stuff though.
Who is a merchant?
Yeah, I have.
You sell?
Yes.
Oh my god, he makes ramen?
Oh shit, nice.
Alright, uh...
I don't need any of this.
Okay.
Wait.
My aid, my inventory...
Wait, I wanted to sell other stuff.
Oh, he only takes like...
Oh, he only takes like, um...
Oh, it's you!
What do you want?
That was me.
Uh...
What was that fight about?
Yeah.
Okay, to be fair, that was sort of obvious.
Tough situation.
Everybody has problems.
Yeah.
Wait!
I can do it!
I'll just get money and I'll do it.
I'm going to go back and talk to him and I want you to come with me.
Of course!
You saw?
He won't take me seriously otherwise.
I don't wanna have to really hurt him.
I just want him to leave Darcy alone.
Bro!
Okay, I need money.
You're gonna have to make it worth my while.
Yeah.
Well, now you've made us look like mere hired thugs!
I mean, I can pay you, but I've only got 80 caps.
Sorry.
I hope it's enough.
Alright.
I'll help.
Sign me up!
It's okay, Cosworth, if you don't like it.
I have Nick Valentine to replace you!
Wait, why do you need me?
If you were just going to talk to him...
Yeah.
Why do you need me along?
I don't want to hurt Cook, but if he doesn't listen to me...
I don't know what I might do.
He won't dare act so smug when he sees you at my back.
And then nobody has to get hurt.
Alright.
Let's do it.
Are you going?
Can you go there faster?
Oh, I should have went there alone so I can just shoot him.
Hey, scabber!
Got plenty of ramen meat on the hook.
Is he going to go or not?
Will you help me talk to Cook?
Get him to leave my wife alone.
Yeah!
I told you I said I'll help!
Okay.
I'll help you.
Good.
I'm sure Cook will back down once he sees you're with me.
Oh, okay.
Let's go.
Okay.
I'll do it alone.
Yeah, I'll do it alone.
This will work better if I talk to Cook by myself.
I don't think so.
Cook might try and talk his way out of it.
And you don't know him like I do.
No!
Now I can't just shoot him!
Oh, nice.
I got $80.
Doesn't matter anyway.
It's alright.
I got $80.
So I'm fine.
It's because he has eyes for his wife only.
That's why my wrist doesn't work, guys.
Guys, he's loyal to his cheating wife.
Which, honestly, you deserve better, man.
You deserve better.
How would you even know that son is yours?
That could be the other guy's.
I don't have zero wrists!
He literally has a wife!
He literally has a wife.
His eyes are only for her!
Can you go faster?
What if I just push him faster?
No, okay.
I fucked up.
Pushing him faster makes him go even slower.
Where is it?
Is that the bar?
Okay, that's the bar over there.
It's open!
Alright.
I can't!
You're in front of the door!
Oh no, he tricked me into doing a loading screen, guys.
You fucking can't.
He tricked me.
I literally can't open the door!
Okay, there we go.
He tricked me to go to the loading screen.
Wait, there's more than one person here.
There's Nelson.
I'm here to watch.
Don't tell me he's hired you to help lean on me.
That's fucking right.
Why do you care?
I should listen to what Paul has to say.
You're making a mistake getting mixed up in this.
Yeah, we're gonna do.
Well, I'm listening, Paul.
What do you have to say this time?
Just this.
Oh my god!
He has a gun?
I would have done this myself.
Very bad idea.
You don't want to pull a gun on me unless you...
Shoot him!
Do it!
It'll be so funny!
Do I just need to kill you?
Is that what you're saying?
Do it!
Give Cook a chance.
Attack Cook.
Calm down.
I just want him to shoot him.
Did I just say attack Cook?
Do it!
I already got my money, though.
You know what?
I already got my money.
Do it!
Better just shoot him, Paul.
Heavens, no!
Mr. Pepper!
This is going to be a...
What the fuck did I...
What did I do?
I did it.
Cogsworth, do you still like me?
Oh, I got water!
Thanks, Cogsworth.
Yeah, how do you feel about us?
Not for the better?
Why not?
I don't understand.
Yeah!
You can head home now.
Right then, Mom.
You know where I'll be.
Whoops!
I did not mean to dismiss him.
Wait, cancel.
Stay with me.
Wait, oh!
Hey, how are you feeling, Paul?
Hey, Paul.
Hell, I gotta get out of here.
You should too, before someone walks in here and pins this on us.
I'm gonna rob him.
Ooh, Cook residence, shotgun.
Double shotgun?
Whoa!
I'm gonna take his suit too.
That's a nice suit.
Wait!
If he's dead, I can rob him?
Cogsworth isn't here anymore, right?
Oh my God.
Wait, he's not here!
Over here!
What?
Wait, he cares?
Don't be late.
What?
I just have to close it.
Wait, you shot me?
Why did he shot me?
It's time for you to shut up and listen, Cook.
What the hell is this?
Wait, did Paul shoot me?
Don't tell me he's hired you to help lean on me.
I can't believe it!
That's right.
You should listen to Paul.
He betrayed me!
You're making a mistake getting mixed up in this.
Stealing is where he draws the line.
I can't believe it.
Just this.
You leave Darcy alone, starting now or else.
He draws the line at stealing.
Now that is a good thing.
You don't want to pull a gun on me unless you intend to use it.
You think I won't use it?
Do I just need to kill you?
Is that what you're saying?
Okay, maybe like...
Wait, okay.
Calm down.
I mean, it's his wife's fault.
Okay, we're good.
Why don't you see if Cook is going to listen?
I'm sure at this point he's properly motivated to hear what you have to say.
Oh, he never listens.
Here we go.
Why me?
Cut!
Okay.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, now he dies?
Wait.
Oh my god, he dies?
Wait, no!
He dies?
Okay, but...
The timeline has changed.
We're going to have a break for a while now and...
Well...
Time to take action.
Past time.
So I have an idea.
Maybe we can help each other?
Put this all behind us, you know?
What's the idea?
Here's the deal.
I have some other, um, businesses on the side.
One of them is helping Nelson Latimer spend his dad's money to make him so he'll feel like a gangster.
Nelson?
Who's Nelson Latimer?
Yeah, who's Nelson Latimer?
An arrogant little pissant.
But useful, since he has all the money in the world and likes to think of himself as a budding crime boss.
Me and Nelson are supposed to be meeting some gentleman from Goodneighbor to exchange Nelson's cash for their chems.
My plan is simple.
We take the money and the chems.
Wait, okay.
Am I just helping the mob now?
Hold on, I have some questions first.
Yeah, what is it?
Yeah, why now?
Why did you screw these guys over all of a sudden?
Oh, it isn't all of a sudden.
Nelson's been complaining about my cut for a while now.
He may be thinking about trying to strike out on his own.
I've been waiting for the right opportunity to present itself.
I'm in here, it is.
Anything else?
I might as well.
That's it.
I think I've known enough.
I'm in.
You know what?
This is the better timeline.
I get more money.
I promise you won't regret it.
In a few hours, we're both going to be sitting here.
Yeah, you know what?
Thank God!
This new timeline is so much better.
I'll get money too.
This is a better timeline.
I'll get a business offer, guys.
Might as well.
I got 80 bottle caps and a business offer?
Yeah, sure.
Why not?
Yeah, screw Paul in this timeline.
I got free stuff.
Something bad went down in the old Museum of Witchcraft up near Cell.
Museum of Witchcraft?
Yeah, Paul already paid me anyway.
Now I get more money.
Exactly.
I did it.
It was a good thing.
Guys, I should sell my stuff.
I should be able to sell my stuff from Rodriguez, right?
New girl?
Who's new girl?
Me?
What can I say?
Names Arturo Rodriguez.
If you need protection, let's talk.
Protection?
Okay, I want to buy I don't want to sell stuff.
Everything hand tooled.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Guys, I don't know what I don't need.
Okay, maybe I don't need...
I don't need road letters.
I don't need...
Oh, I have so many guns.
I have so many clothes.
Alright, we don't need all these.
We can sell one of that.
Synthetic truce.
Oh, I want to keep all the Voltex stuff.
I want to sell...
Okay, I don't need another photo book.
I don't need...
I don't need all that.
Uhhh...
What else do I not need?
There's so many things though.
Oh yeah, you guys said that pipe stuff are bad.
So I'll sell all my pipe stuff.
Uhhh...
What's the jet?
Oh, it slows time?
Uhhh...
I need all of these though.
I don't need two masks.
Switch categories?
What do you mean?
You guys all said pipe guns are terrible.
Okay, I can sell that.
I need all these grenades.
Uhhh...
I have so many good items.
It's so hard to...
Okay, we can...
I think we can sell majority of our clothes.
I admit that we don't need all of these clothes.
Like...
We can always grab more suits.
We can always grab more of these.
Uhhh...
Oh, is the leather better than the...
Is the leather better than the raider?
No, it's not.
So I can sell the leather ones.
Uhhh...
Okay, I need all the aid and stuff.
Misc...
Miscillaneous...
Munts...
Ammo...
Oh my god!
512?
Okay, maybe not 512.
I can sell like 200 of that.
Right?
Yeah.
And that should be good.
Confirm trade.
Yay!
So thirsty.
The game changer!
Doctor says I can't drink liquor no more.
Alright.
Well, ammo doesn't weigh anything.
Well, it's okay.
It's fine.
It's fine, guys.
I'm so thirsty.
It's okay.
I want money.
I did it!
I'm a hero!
I'm a friend!
I did it!
Give me the money!
Pay me.
About my reward.
They always gotta ruin the moment with money talk.
Here.
Every cap we agreed to for finding him.
A little extra!
Cause she likes me.
Wait, the little extra is a fucking fedora that I'm gonna sell.
One case at a time, Ellie.
Our new friend needs our help first.
Alright, let's get down to business.
Take a seat.
Okay.
I can finally sit for real.
Hahaha.
I'm trying to find someone who's gone missing.
The devil is in the details.
Tell me everything you can.
No matter how painful it might be.
Uh...
Sean.
You're looking for my baby, Sean.
He's less than a year old.
Why would anyone take him?
Welcome to Jermia Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Why an infant?
Someone would be taking on all of his care.
And a baby needs a lot of it.
What else can you tell me?
Um...
He killed my husband's not that important.
You were in a vault when it happened.
Vault 111.
It was some kind of cryo facility.
You were on ice, huh?
More importantly, you were underground.
Sealed up.
There's a lot of obstacles to get through just to take one path.
Oh, he's dead!
I gotta move on!
My husband's dead!
My kidnaps.
There was a man and a woman.
They didn't say much, but I remember they called me the backup.
So we're talking a small team.
Professionals.
The kind that know to keep their lips tight when they're on the job.
Not sure what the backup means, though.
Cogsberry, what are you doing?
This isn't a random kidnapping.
Whoever took your kid had an agenda.
Hmm.
It's a lot of work.
There's a lot of groups in the Commonwealth that take people.
Raiders, super mutants, the gunners.
And of course there's the Institute.
The Institute?
So you think this Institute is responsible?
Well, they're the boogeymen of the Commonwealth.
Something goes wrong, everyone blames them.
Easy to see why.
Those early models since of theirs strip whole towns for parts, killing everything in their way.
Wait, I wanna join the Institute!
The Commonwealth is as good as human, but infiltrates cities and pulls strings from the shadows.
Worst of all, no one knows why they do it, what their plan is, or where they are.
Not even you.
I'm a synth myself.
A discarded prototype, anyway.
Wait, you're one of them.
You're a prototype?
As far as I know.
Never seen any other synth like myself.
There's the older ones that are dumb as rocks and all metal.
And there's the newer ones that are almost human.
I'm somewhere in between.
Yeah, like you're really- you can tell you're really, really old.
Don't lie to me, Nick.
You're one of them.
They made you.
Yeah, I've heard it all before.
You're a freak.
You've got something to hide.
Yeah, freak.
Wait, aren't you programmed to support the Institute?
People smart enough to build something like me are smart enough to cover their tracks.
And arrogant enough to throw their unwanted trash.
I'm not a freak.
I'm a big fan of the Commonwealth.
And fend for itself.
Either way, I need to find Sean.
You're right.
The speculation's getting closer...
Don't be mean to Nick.
What did these kidnappers look like?
Oh, he broke his programming?
He broke his programming?
He carried a gun!
That eliminates like one person.
I'll never forget that voice.
That's like everybody in the wasteland.
He was bald.
He had no hair just like you, Nick.
Kellogg?
The serial?
Did he name himself after the serial because he saw a cereal box?
It's Sean.
He's 10 now.
If it's another kid, it has to be Sean.
There's no other children in this world.
Who else could it be?
There's no other children here.
How do I make him join my team, guys?
Nick, join my team.
Nick, I don't care about Cox.
Join my team.
Nick.
No!
Join my team, Nick!
I can't open the door, Nick!
Oh, I finished the quest?
Okay.
I want Nick to join my team and replace Cogsworth.
You talk to a kid when you're... She doesn't count.
She's not a kid.
Please.
Why does it take forever to load back?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
I jumped a gun there.
Alright, where do we have to go?
Where do we go?
I don't want Ellie to hear this, but I think you should know.
Everything I dug up about bad news...
What do you mean by that?
More than just a mercenary.
He's a professional.
Quick, clean, thorough.
Has no enemies.
Because they're all dead.
Oh, that's scary.
Except you.
Nine to one odds says he's our man.
More than just you identifying his distinctions.
He's got some distinguishing features.
The M.O.
is all him as well.
Leading a small team to kidnap a baby and leaving one of the parents alive for later?
Not many mercs in the Commonwealth can pull that off.
What is it?
No!
Oh my god.
This takes fucking forever.
Can you run?
Can you at least run?
Like, please!
How far is this place that I have to go?
Okay.
Where's the objective of this quest?
It doesn't even tell me.
Are you done talking?
Like, can you go a little faster?
Please, why can't you run?
That's all I ask of you.
This is it?
Keep an eye out, will you?
See if I can get this open.
Oh my god.
He's perfect.
He can unlock doors.
What can you do?
What can... exactly.
Walk away.
Wait, you can't unlock this?
Oh my god!
I can't do it!
I'm not smart enough!
We need to find a key?
Where?
Can he actually jimmy the lock?
No, okay.
Oh, that yellow one?
Oh my god, thank god it's in yellow.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Alright, it's this one, right?
Yeah.
This has to be it.
Parkour!
Alright, we gotta get a key.
Push.
Goodbye, Cosworth.
You're fucking useless.
I can't wait to replace you with a better fucking robot.
You're not even hot!
That used you for eye candy.
Wow, rude.
What, you think Cosworth's hot?
I'm running.
Do you ever think maybe you could get a man's attention easier if you use soft keys on him?
Whoa!
And shout a little less?
Oh my god, she doesn't need no man!
She needs a woman.
Hey, girl.
You first.
What are you doing here, Piper?
Nuh-uh.
Not until it's in print.
You can read all about it in the next issue.
If you are done crowding the reception area, Miss Piper, the mayor needs to make time for more... responsible citizens.
I was just leaving anyway.
The mayor's receiving visitors as long as they aren't members of the press.
Did you need help?
I need to get Kellogg's house.
I need to talk to someone about Kellogg's old house in the West End.
I didn't like her anyway, guys.
I didn't like her.
She's just not my type.
If there was something belonging to the man that you had left out...
It's not that she rejected me.
It's that I rejected her before she could reject me.
I don't have time.
I need that key now.
Why is finding this key so important to you, honey?
Do I have money?
Oh, I don't want to give my money away.
Just trust me.
I'll throw a threat at you.
Wait, I'll find my... finding my babies.
All I want to do is find my baby.
The man who owned that house.
Kidnapped him.
I've heard the sob stories before.
So save them.
Bitch!
Can I threaten her?
Look at me.
I should do.
Just trust me.
It's important.
You have my word.
You really thought that would work, didn't you?
I don't think so.
What?
Fine!
Take my 250.
Maybe we can reach an agreement.
Fine!
I don't need the bottle caps.
For me?
Oh, how generous.
Oh, there I go again.
Leaving a key out on my desk and forgetting to put it back.
I don't need the... It's okay.
It's alright.
Fine.
I don't need it.
I don't fucking need it.
I don't need the money anyway.
I'll just steal it back.
Where does she live?
I'm gonna steal those caps back.
I should have stolen it, guys.
Why?
Why did I give her my money?
Alright, let's see.
We gotta go to Kellogg's place.
Wait, how do I get to Kellogg's place?
Is it here?
Wait, how do I do that?
I forgot how to get there naturally.
Hahaha!
Like, oh, it's like here.
Oh, it's over here.
I see the stairs.
Alright.
I'm smart!
I have true intelligence!
That's smart enough!
That's enough to pass, like, first grade.
It's the wasteland!
You don't need to be smart.
You just gotta have the fucking guns.
I do.
I got the keys.
And even for my baby boy.
Let's take a look around.
Kellogg must have left something behind.
Oh!
Oh, I can steal now!
Surely you meant to leave that rubbish where you found it.
Place seems small to you.
I can sell it all.
I can make back the money I lost.
I can make back all the money I lost, guys.
This is it.
Nothing here.
Did you check out that desk?
Is there something on the desk?
You don't understand Cogsworth!
You don't fucking care!
Where is it?
The broom?
Hey, Valentine.
What is it?
It's so small!
It has to be... No, that's not it.
That's just a bed.
There's another sleeping bag.
There's two sleeping bags here.
Did you see it?
Where is it?
Hidden?
Oh, I'm hidden.
Huh?
Oh my god, I got a big book.
Found
it!
I'm so smart!
Nuka-Cola!
Look at this.
Hey, Valentine.
Look at that.
All of Kellogg's favorite things.
Oh my god, look at all these free stuff.
Oh my god, used oil.
Stout beer.
44 caliber bullets.
Cigars.
Oh my god, Stimpaks!
I need those!
Hmm, interesting brand.
Won't lead us anywhere on its own, though.
And guns!
Any suggestions, Nuka?
Hmm.
What about dog meat?
How do you know about dog meat?
A man sent for miles.
Why don't you go fetch him and let him have a whiff?
See if he picks up the trail.
Before you head out, I know this is personal business.
If you have to face Kellogg on your own, just say so.
Besides, you already have plenty of company.
You can't all go sniffing through the Commonwealth after one man.
Wait, come with me!
I want you with me.
Is he my companion now?
Oh my god, yes!
Leave!
I'm my new best friend!
You say jump, I'll say how high.
Yeah!
Time!
He's my new companion now!
Let's go!
Get out!
I found a hotter robot for my eye candy.
Leave me alone, Cogsworth.
Grosses!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
King shaming for robot appearances now, Doki!
Shake my head!
Look, if I'm gonna have a robot that's gonna follow me around, he better be good eye candy for me.
I'm gonna have to get rid of him.
This one's hotter.
He has legs.
Where are your legs, Cogsworth?
Oh hey, Dogmeat, you're here.
Dogmeat, get the scent, boy.
Yeah, get the scent.
Got the scent?
Got something, boy.
Let's go!
Is that Cogsworth just slowly walking me?
He's walking back?
That's right.
Slowly do the walk of shame, Cogsworth!
That's fucking right!
Look at the person I replaced you with!
Head over there.
Legs are DLC.
When Cogsworth gets those legs, then we'll talk.
The walk of shame.
Yeah!
He has to know his place, guys.
Oh no.
Back to loading screen.
Back to the loading screen.
Alright, here we go.
Where is it, Dogmeat?
Where is he?
Where's my son?
How far is it?
Come on, boy.
Where the fuck is my son?
Oh, I need to charge my AP.
Oh my god, I forgot to get back all my...
No!
Cogsworth is holding so much of my items!
Oh no.
I knew I forgot to do something.
I forgot to take back my items.
Wait.
Is he somewhere?
Dogmeat, pick up the Santa Can.
Kellogg's preferred brand, alright.
Okay, boy.
Let's track him.
Search for these.
He took everything in the divorce.
I can't believe it.
No!
And I said... I forgot to take the stuff back before I...
Before I shithocked him.
Now he's gonna throw them all away!
He's gonna throw them to the curb!
He's gonna throw it from a balcony!
Woo!
Oh!
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
Guys!
Why did you not tell me to heal?
Why did you not tell me to heal, guys?
Nuka Cola.
Yeah.
Fucking... Fuck off.
Fuck off!
Yeah!
What is Nick?
Nick!
Oh my god.
I need to eat these guys.
Oh shit!
He's extra radiated!
I'm crippled!
Bro!
Oh!
That's a dog!
Oh my god.
I'm limping.
Somebody help!
There's a stim pack!
Did I not loot stim packs?
Oh I did.
Okay.
I'm okay now.
It was just... I'm okay now.
I'm not...
I can walk again.
I can walk again, guys.
Go to the stat screen?
Why?
Can I upgrade?
Oh I can!
I need one... No I can.
You guys lied.
Oh.
Yes.
Use vats?
I don't need vats.
I have pure skill.
Super chat!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Can't believe it.
Those fucking moles.
Oh I can use stim packs from this... Oh I can use stim packs from the stat screen!
Vats... Vats are for pussies!
I don't need vats when I can smash!
Come on!
Go DocMe!
Go!
Where is he?
Search clues for Kellogg?
In here?
Blood splatters?
Look at the blood splatters.
Whoa!
What the f- Oh!
That's what I looted from!
Oh hey.
Look at all these free stuff.
What did you see, boy?
What is it, boy?
Bloody bandages.
Dogmeat can track this.
Okay, boy.
Let's track him.
Yeah.
No need for vats when she got the vats.
Exactly, Zane!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Exactly!
Alright.
Where are they?
Oh shit!
The evil five!
There you go.
Bad boy!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
This is why I got you, Nick!
Bam!
Oh!
Did you see that dog fight?
Bro, my dog- This is the legal type of dog fighting.
Because those are evil dogs.
Wait, we did it, DogMeat.
Wait, where's DogMeat?
Where did he go?
Where did DogMeat go?
Wait, actually, where the fuck did my dog go?
Guys, I lost my dog.
Guys.
I lost him.
My dog's gone.
They're evil dogs!
We just literally saw two dogs fighting.
Wait, where's DogMeat?
DogMeat!
DogMeat?
Where did DogMeat go?
I need to turn on the quest.
I might as well.
Reunions.
Follow DogMeat.
Where did he go?
Oh, he went this way.
Is that it?
Is that the real quest?
No.
This is the quest.
He's over here.
Oh, he's barking at me!
He's calling me stupid!
Bro, DogMeat!
Wear a vest!
We need to wear a reflected vest, DogMeat!
DogMeat, I can barely see where you are!
I'll loot that.
Come on, DogMeat.
Where are they?
Where's Kellogg?
The cereal.
Oh my god, that's a bear.
That's a bear.
That's a fucking bear!
DogMeat, why?!
I can't fucking fight a bear!
Oh, I'm gonna fight a bear.
I'm gonna fight a bear.
Oh, that is not the...
Oh!
Okay, but what?
Oh...
How much damage do I do?
I do...
Oh!
That was a mistake!
Guys...
I don't...
I...
It's not just a bear.
This is...
Guys, it was not just a bear.
Guys...
Guys, it was...
It was...
Oh my god.
I had to fight the dogs again?!
Alright, guys.
It was not just a bear.
I've learned...
I've learned that it was absolutely much worse than just a bear.
Alright.
It was...
It was a radioactive bear.
I can't believe I didn't save.
I can't believe we're gonna kill a bear today.
It's okay.
Okay.
Low seven to low fifteen zone.
What, like it's hard?
We can do this!
I believe in us!
Can't be that difficult!
Okay.
We're gonna be so fine.
We're gonna be so healthy.
Alright, we're gonna grab...
let's see, a comfort grip.
Uh... ooh, this is a better pistol actually.
And then... oh, I should grab a shotgun.
Nevermind, I'm grabbing a shotgun.
We're gonna be fucking shooting bears.
We're gonna grab a...
What the fuck?
I'd rather just fucking grab a pistol.
These guys take so long!
Bro, what the fuck?
It was easier to just...
Wow!
Okay, I'm fucking grabbing a...
The shotgun sucks!
The shotgun fucking sucks!
What the hell?
Look at this pistol.
Watch this pistol.
Oh my god, the pistol is faster.
Look, see?
Wait, no.
Yeah, the pistol is so much faster!
I need some dog meat.
Alright.
Alright guys, I gotta figure this out.
I gotta...
I gotta figure this out what gun to use.
Cause all these guns fucking suck.
The auto-pistol.
Let's see.
Uhhhh...
I don't know!
What's the best gun to fight the...
The minigun?
To fight the bear?
Okay.
Okay, maybe...
This gun.
This gun would be okay.
Alright, we're gonna save.
We're gonna save.
Alright.
We're gonna see a bear soon.
It's bear time.
Oh, that's the worst gun I could use?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, maybe...
We can do something with this gun, right?
Where's the bear?
Is he here?
Is he here again?
Is the bear back?
Wait.
Was I just...
Oh, wait.
There he is.
Oh, god.
Hit it.
No!
Give me the crit!
Is that...
Oh, god!
Nick, shoot him!
Nick, shoot him for the love of god!
Shoot the bear!
Oh, god.
Nick, shoot him!
Sacrifice yourself!
Nick, sacrifice yourself for me!
Don't you ever...
Oh, I ran out of ammo.
I ran out of ammo.
It's waterproof.
Oh my god!
I fucking knew you would reject!
No!
Holy shit.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Oh my god, please, dog, please reject.
I'm trying.
Oh, the dragon buster!
The dragon buster!
Oh god!
Reload, reload, reload, reload, reload!
Reload, reload, reload!
Nick!
Take this Nick!
Take this!
Good job Nick!
Oh my god, where is he?
Oh my god, I can't even see him.
You got this Nick!
3%!
I'll take my odds!
Oh my god.
Did I hit him?
Guys, I don't think I'll hit him.
It's okay!
You got this Nick!
We did it.
It was that easy.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, we fucking did it.
Oh my god, let me fucking save.
Holy fuck.
Okay, we did it.
Use your companions as bait so you can live.
The Doki Bridge trap.
Guys, who wants to be my companion guys?
Not even close.
We did it.
You're right.
It's not we.
I did it.
You're right guys.
You're right.
I did it.
You know the drill.
What's this?
Are you fucking kidding me?
A decoy, huh?
Clever.
Is this enough?
Is that it?
Wait, where did... where Dogmeat is?
Where he is?
Oh hey, more clues.
Oh, more sitting down.
Alright.
Where you wanna go, Dogmeat?
Where are you going?
Where are we going, Dogmeat?
Woah woah woah woah woah.
Oh
my god, there's more?
How much more?
Vicious Snar?
Don't worry, Dogmeat.
I'll come over.
I got the gains.
See, it's that easy.
Oh shit.
Easy.
LEGENDARY!
Okay.
Did I miss?
How did I miss?
Oh god.
Don't let him hit me.
No!
Oh my god, you're fucking kidding me.
You brought it to... Okay.
Okay guys.
How was I supposed to know?
He one-shots!
Oh thank god.
At least I saved after the bear.
Oh thank god I saved after the bear.
Oh thank fucking god.
I would've been so sad.
If I had to do the bear again.
Oh my god.
It was planned, chat.
It was planned so I can...
So I can disarm this.
A decoy, huh?
Clever.
Guys, it was planned.
Do I hit it?
Guys, don't hit it.
Guys.
Okay, I'm gonna call it here.
I think...
I'm gonna call it here.
I...
I think that's a good...
This is where we're calling it today.
I think that was the point where I was like, my mind's not working anymore.
My...
I don't... You guys were like, oh you can disarm it.
Use your vats and you can disarm it.
But I think somebody meant like, use your vats to find... find... like, mines.
But then I thought like, oh use my vats to disarm it.
That's where my mind went into.
But then I realized, oh they meant like, if you can't... don't know where the mines are, you can use your vats.
But I didn't read the last part.
I read the beginning where someone said, use vats.
And then I didn't read the end of the sentence.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know Piper is a good companion to you.
She has a face and legs.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But she's not a hot robot.
That's the only thing.
Guys.
That's the only thing that like, is the deal breaker.
Oh my god.
Today was a very long, long day today.
I'm sorry I didn't stream more fun.
Sorry I didn't do a longer fun stream.
But we did a really long Monopoly stream.
So I'm gonna add that in together.
So it was a double stream today.
But I did have a lot of fun today.
Guys, I hope you guys had a lot of fun as well.
Chat.
It was a very, very long day.
But I hope you guys enjoyed today.
I actually didn't even eat dinner yet.
I didn't eat dinner yet.
So I'm gonna go and order some food for dinner.
But it really was a great time just spending my day with you guys.
And as always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Sorry it was like a really quick ending everyone.
Sorry, sorry.
I just really want to get food.
So I can't chat for too long.
Because I won't order food before like places close down.
So I'll see you guys the day after tomorrow.
Bye bye.